we started collecting scans in 1999 we
don't really know why we did that but
little by little we collected them we
archive them and one day we opened those
files and we had almost 4,000 or 5,000
scans scams are kind of first spammed
internet very specific because it's take
forms of a narrative where people take
other personalities and ask you to help
them because I have a huge amount of
money and and you're the only person I
can trust to help them to get this money
out of place usually and we were very
interested in the narratives that the
scams were you know constructing there
was a kind of writing of history here
and so scans were revealing a kind of
imaginary of corruption and we were very
interested to deconstruct them and to
see what we can do with them and one of
our question is how people can believe
in such stories it's helped a lot to
deal with our own practice as filmmaker
and artist when you start a fan you
always wonder how people will believe in
my story how an actor will play a
character and being convincing certain
contexts make you believe that this
story is possible or not so the relation
between sham context and storytelling is
very important for us and why why do you
answer like why do an answer to someone
you will never see that maybe you will
never meet and your answer and you you
develop a relation so this is a question
about trust to believe and trust it has
nothing to do it with being naive it's a
desire to believe in something
it's exactly like in a love story or in
in cinema you know that it's a fake
story but nevertheless
want to enter it you have the desire to
believe in it and thus can for you to
believe it needs to be very well set up
so you have some characters you have to
have a good script a good narrative then
you have to have a Rolex of shoes or
sign X 2 a sign that makes people
believe so you have all those things
that you use in a production of a film
that becomes very important to to trap
someone and to make him believe so a
scam is constructed as a narrative and
as a film in the height of the scammers
so we wanted to show to be like a film
that unfolds where you have characters
that come back you have not only stories
but a kind of stories that we are all
part of stories that we cannot say oh it
will never happen to me because we never
know we all want to believe and we all
want to be part of your relation with
the other sometimes it's terrible for
the victim sometimes it's very cruel
also but sometimes there is a kind of
poetic encounters that happens and we
wanted to make it to make sure that all
of that is in the show and that when you
get out of the show there is no answers
as a lot of questions
you